[Música]
economía en directo américa de france 24
y ya está conmigo en el estudio daniela
blandón daniela bienvenida bueno tenerla
como siempre en este estudio hoy vamos a
tratar un tema especial en esta sección
económica la batalla legal entre hilo
mask y twitter danny en qué va esta
demanda hola raúl pues vamos al grano el
25 de abril de este año el
multimillonario de los nuevos que acordó
la compra del 100 por ciento de twitter
a través de una función por un precio de
44 mil millones de dólares hoy la firma
vale un poco menos de 34 mil millones de
dólares en bolsa pues busca decidió
apartarse del negocio y twitter quiere
hacerlo cumplir a toda costa el caso
llegó a un pequeño pero poderoso
tribunal de delaware especializado en
grandes peleas empresariales y que
realizará un juicio de cinco días en
octubre consultamos con juan pabló coi
el trabajo con la superintendencia
financiera de colombia raúl que equivale
a la comisión de valores de eeuu que es
justamente la entidad que vigila a las
empresas que cotizan en bolsa y le
preguntamos pues cómo cree que va a
terminar este caso esto nos dijo que él
está manifestando que lo que pasa es que
él no sabe cuántos bots
como programas
que se hacen pasar como personas reales
en twitter que él no ha podido tener
certeza de los mismos en eso twitter se
defiende y dice que lo que está haciendo
es un sabotaje que yo le han dado toda
la información ellos tienen disponible
salvo que se hiciera una revisión cuenta
por cuenta donde tendría que dar los
datos personales con violación del
derecho de intimidad de las personas que
son dueñas de las cuentas en eso mi
opinión es la siguiente la secc la
securities exchange commission es una
entidad supremamente seria es una
entidad política o sea no es partidista
es una entidad muy profesional conozco
mucho de sus funcionarios y yo sé que
ellos han hecho el mejor trabajo con la
mejor información disponible de que las
información
y periódica y relevante que le otorga y
'twitter' a la sec y al mercado en
general y a los inversionistas y de sus
accionistas es completamente
transparente o de lo que ellos tienen
entonces por eso vemos muy difícil que
no nos pueda salir avante en este
proceso si nosotros pues poder decir
cuál será con certeza pero hay un temor
de parte de él porque por eso está
convenido por eso se está llenando de
caja para poder cumplir
daniela pero cuáles son en este momento
los argumentos de twitter bueno en una
demanda de 62 páginas twitter acusa al
multimillonario de que su oferta vino
acompañada de amenazas también que actúa
de manera hipócrita y de mala fe y que
ha utilizado mal la información que le
han entregado inclusive porque quiere
habría querido crear un competidor al
tener una posición tan importante dentro
de la misma twitter porque él tiene un
buen porcentaje yo entiendo que cercano
al 10 por ciento pues él tiene que ser
mucho más medido con lo que hice y
además de eso pues él tiene un deber de
confidencialidad por los acuerdos que
tengo con twitter para la compra de la
totalidad la compañía
yo sí pienso que tendría mucha
responsabilidad en el sentido de decir
estrictamente lo necesario
porque es que él tiene una situación muy
complicada porque al ser accionista
tener tanta participación cualquier cosa
que él diga puede llegar a mover el
precio de la acción y por eso la secc en
otros casos no en twitter pero sí sé que
al menos en tesla le han hecho
requerimientos de información para que
le explique de dónde está sacando lo que
está diciendo ahora todo el mundo tiene
derecho a expresión y más en eeuu donde
está la enmienda primera sin embargo
pues en esas dos consideraciones que él
tiene hoy a una porción accionaria
importante de twitter que además de eso
está en un proceso de fusión adquisición
pues entendería que él tiene mucha mayor
responsabilidad la de cualquier
inversionista o ciudadano pero daniela
sin embargo él no se quedó de brazos
cruzados sino que lo menos contra
demandó a la compañía claro que 665
páginas de contrademandar las que el
considerado hombre más rico del mundo se
defiende su principal argumento es que
las cuentas falsas o spam
presentan muchísimo más que ese 5 que
dice twitter y eso hace que el negocio
ya no sea tan atractivo inclusive lo
acusó de fraude y de bloquear cuentas
probó craneanas para favorecer al
gobierno ruso entre muchas otras cosas
le preguntamos a nuestro invitado que
estaría buscando entonces cada parte
está respuesta a la hora terminar
resolviendo la corte de canciller y de
chanson y del estado de delaware porque
digamos él está sosteniendo que él no
tiene que pagar nada porque una persona
versar el efecto adverso un efecto
material adverso en su contra y twitter
está diciendo que él realmente porque
twitter no está pidiendo los millones de
dólares twitter lo que está pidiendo es
que se junta con el acuerdo de buena fe
y que él no está actuando de buena fe y
que precisamente lo que está haciendo es
una forma de afectar a largo plazo el
valor de twitter
entonces él lo interesante de esto es
que esa esa respuesta no la va a dar en
el club es de cancillería porque el ente
ambas cosas que me preguntaste la están
sosteniendo las dos puntas de las dos
contrapartes entonces va a ser muy
interesante mirar el juicio para ver qué
ocurre van a ser cinco días que tengo
que son bastante en un proceso tan
especializado como este y que tenemos
después de toda esta novela como si fue
el día de la relacionada por supuesto
con esta novela seis mil 900 millones de
dólares en acciones de tesla que vendió
el dueño y fundador de esta compañía y
lo más que esta semana el argumento es
que los fondos podrían usarse para
financiar el posible acuerdo de twitter
si es que lo obligan a comprar la
empresa tal y como siempre muchísimas
gracias por toda la información nos
vemos luego